es el primer gran incendio forestal del
año las llamas comenzaron el domingo en
el sur de Francia cientos de hectáreas
fueron arrasadas en la costa
mediterránea francesa antes de
extenderse a través de la frontera con
España el ministro del interior francés
gerald Maná estuvo en el lugar de los
hechos y atribuyó el incendio al cambio
climático
estos incendios están acelerando por el
calentamiento global y por el hecho de
que este departamento no ha visto llover
desde hace cinco meses se prevé que
Francia vivirá Un verano aún más seco
que la sequía récord que sufrió el año
pasado esto se debe a que los niveles de
agua subterránea es decir el agua que se
almacena en el suelo y evita que se
seque están en mínimos históricos según
un informe reciente el 80% de los
acuíferos del país están por debajo de
los niveles normales seis botellas siete
botellas de agua en la semana El domingo
no podemos tomar hay restricciones que
están en curso desde hace mucho tiempo
pero restringir el consumo de agua
potable es la primera vez Durante este
invierno Francia vivió el periodo de
sequía más largo de su historia debido a
la falta de precipitaciones los
agricultores han tenido que regar ellos
mismos lo que ha empeorado la situación
el presidente francés Emmanuel Mako ha
pedido nuevas medidas para ahorrar el
agua y ha dicho que todos los sectores
deben reducir su consumo de agua en un
10% para 2030